And in the time. They turned to find the tweezers to tug of that tick. From the tip of the dick.
They had children and children's children. That grew a coat of many colors. About them. That waxed.
In the old wave of their whining. Aquarian waters. That washed and fed to the child. That poured the life. In the day.
Of a day in the life of newman. In my village in rattled hair. And proud rags.
There are dead stop travellers wrapped in concrete. Find silver rings p. Is there is no use in leaps and nipples.
There are people sleeping under my arm under my pillow. Under my dreams. Under my children under mine money.
Under my pipes under my wiring. And a rats. And dogs down in the old arsenic and have. Declawed us.
They sleep under my sleep. On the carpet. Of my winter's half. Around the bend. I hold my baby on my one street. Town.
I walk past my paper man. Past my glossy magazine fantasies. My princess allee's and my princess di.
And my princess caroline. Pass the glossy to use and gowns. I walk past my real the state persons.
People are sleeping under my real estate persons. Sleep walking sleep or dealing. Sleep talking outside my. Rainbow.
Cafe. They are raining. Inside my rainbow. Sad drizzling rain or. Tables of glass eyes rolling.
And they're smoking up a storm. Riving and rainbows and arrows. People are sleeping under my footsteps.
Lying to my face. They are dying. Into my our eyes. My street. Is their bedroom. Argument.
My foot path the backdoor bathroom fix. A kitchen sink quarrel. For them into my eyes. An argument about bags and.
Debts. And loans and threats. About manny. And where were you.
And where is more i money and you reaped me off when i was ripping you off. When you ripped me off. The rip rip rap.
The riff raff rap. The rag tag. Tit for tat. I am wall to the window. Do you wanna buy a bag of boardroom.
Microphone to their man hours. Just water for glass eyes to sail. Nor spoon fed in today about.
To use to tolerate a once in chanted drug. Down the track to being stoned. Just to be nearly normal.
To be nearly normal. Newman. Labels. Of by bulls. There's hippies and yuppies. And greenies. And junkies. And drinking.
Smokers and tokers. And dug through the east. And jokers and motors. Ball kickers and ball hit is ball terrors with.
Pit bull terriers.
Drummers and dances and dipsticks and double goes your bows into rows and muse are those and prego and embryos.
Journos and two rows and muse are in a study again. And mr line. Too caught up and putting you. Labels. Of. Paypal's.
There's he peace. And yuppies. And greenies. And junkies. And drinking. These. Smokers and tokers.
And dope three kids and jokers and police bull kickers. And ball hit is and ball. Terrors with. Pit bull terriers.
Drummers and dances and dipsticks and doubles yobbos and two rows and music goes and. Prego and embryos.
Journos and photos and layers of those and homos. Sapiens. And heteros a peons and not. Sapiens.
Stone to builders and mud brick is an organic. Effluent powered plumbers and joiners. Metal men. And amazons.
And the goddess in the kitchen. There's painters and powers. And potters.
And butchers and bakers and candlestick makers cobblers and weavers and would turn as in tyler's. Mad hatters.
And mask makers and face painters and glass bead game shakers. As yogis. And barbers and babies and swamis and sharman.
And shimon and sue fees and service and skaters and bikers. Ferals and herbals and wheelers and dealers.
And when ckers. And yankee. And japanese. And jerry's. And frenchies.
And pommies and mad irish to be sure to be sure to be shiite. To be shiva. To be. You pray. To be washed out.
Watered down. Unemployed and inspired to be youth.
To be attained age
or to be secondary primary infant preschool daycare aftercare careless care free we're there to care. To be unheard.
Anon. Just to be seen and smelt and passed on the street. A pedestrian a shopper. A robber. A dawber a copper a cream.
A loiterer a waiter a torker a laser tanned a lizard. An outpatient a schizo a dip so. As on be a run away.
To be a coffee stop. To be froth and farmers and grazes.
And gardeners and lawyers or to carlos' an aggros to be a shooter. To be shocked. Cyberpunks and funky s.
and Goblins and gothics and rest isn't a rat's day trippers and night trippers. And trapped in their trips.
Tripped out trippy trekkers and turned on tantric tale tellers. Divine lighters and cloud liners and takeaway diners.
To be loved is to be left overs. To be left right up down has to be round and round as.
Weekend workshop as an codependent conference hopper's.
Midlife crises for midwives with vices and shotgun divorces over him and horses. To be labels.
To be labels to be glue sniffers. Of a stick. On labels. In the cafes. Of the streets. Of the table. On the road.
From bible. To babylon. To burke and. Back. Easter parade. They drive on up. From the city of yup.
They come on down to the radical town. The one street. Town of the hippie. And the clown.
Year old hairy man and young barefoot woman with suckling bay. Mrs no brothers and mr battered to cars. To see a life.
That's free free love. Free drugs. Free music. Free footpath free gata free falling over. Free flight. And free fights.
And what's not free. Just to see. They walk the town all city fled for a bit of a deer. But then they skated.
Their culture shocked. Their culture locked. And in the mind of. Travel their ships.
Dry docked for their clubs are white an issues so bright this skin is white their teeth pale white their car is nice
and their kids like mice. With heavy metal make a death switch at hype.
They window shop they smell the part or they sniff the calf. But they don't stop.
No cash or koreans bulge their fashion lines. For their credit card is razor fine.
It cuts a slice they can call mind simply divine. And it's mine. They ask.
Where are the real hippies in their mind are we say. You're standing on one side or. Is that chap.
Really chained to a dog. And his mate. Looks the queen of the bog. Triffids dulux. Zombies. Prodigals parasites.
Psycho movie. Extras and the great unwashed. Oh lord. But come ye. Of bunnies on a crucifixion dawn.
We're nailing chocolate coated junkies under crosses so full blown. Not with niles. But syringes.
And not for soft heart. Freak show cringes. But for the crowd and the cameras and the mums and dads and kids.
Tunnelvision unscrews from their third eye. It guides them safe back to their car. Bye-bye. We dust.
Their footprints from our face. Climb down from the cross and clean up the place. Bury hoses. Shopkeepers sweep.
And scavengers a lick of nuggets from the street. The streets of nym been aligned with mad.
Over god all lined with the purple green we did. That's worth. As god with peace and guns and plenty.
And poverty and law and. Anik come and see or better still piss off. Was written in october. Nine hundred ninety six.
Nimbin rise or mirror. It was a town where we use to love each other in the streets. In the power. In the rainbow.
To hug and hold and mess. Some say no it wasn't. It was never better even before the snack attack.
The sharp edge was their axe blade wedge saw. Plow. Brush gutter. Knife a century of timber cutters and cane cutters.
Liz moore was a two day hike. Before they wiped the ritzy different their path. Wild men.
Few women two wars a depression isolation. A recession of one industry. To kind. Into the next. The hills.
Strewn with the bones. Trees and. Belief in derry. Till the town was neither goes. And the valley.
Was ripe for the hippie. Then came the word. And the word was god. Smiling down checks and benefits and grants.
A festival the. Still life. Born again mushrooms. Pregnant. On astroturf. The deliberately poor became multiple.
Occupants. Booming babies. Building broken families building the house the trees. Rebuilding the car.
Rewinding relationships through a hassle of hope and rip off the drop kicks of drew and. Up. And strange drop outs.
Feeding friendship through a slot machine. The sweetness turns savery savvy one streetwise. In the mirror of the knife.
The mirror. Of the needle. Words and. Eyes can still kept the rusted away. Wrists cold. On the cheek. Of the valley.
And we who used to love. We have a spit and white stone honing that blade. Losing. Each other into the rays it.
History of the valley only we can she think the anger. And the knife. Hockey going. Rainbow rabbit.
Mira go around the forest. Dusty hippies while dreaming caravans watching compost walls.
And the logging trucks rolled past. Flapping plastic windows. Beast. Turns turtle. Turns based. Turns bored.
In a heartbeat. Changing channels. Changing tires in a month to grumble. Seed planting a jungle bored. Nic.
I missed the beginning of that. Rainbow rabbit. Merry go round the forests. Dusty hippies wild dreaming caravans.
Watching compost. Walls. And the logging trucks roll. Past. Flapping plastic windows. Beast. Turns turtle. Turns beast.
Turns bored. In a heartbeat. Changing channels. Changing tires in a mad grumble. Seed planting a jungle. Bog.
Nit picking snakes in ticks. Blow fly blow in helicopters sniffing drugs. Paradise bird startle.
Waving at a sunset showers. The last rainbow. Fades the mountain and twilight crashes the valley.
Fresh dripping terraces of flowers and greens. Breathe into nine. The car breaks down. The town wakes up friday.
Driving drink and drugs. Forrest with backs. Rural debutantes. Dog face in the hippie. Farmer smith in black can brown.
Storekeepers barefoot natives. And the black cracking livers of gypsy junkies. Changing bandages and bend down as.
Changing small change. Into broken veins. All rubbing together in the front bar.
And seeing them hit the drum fix the car and get out. Back into the main while. Of the gumboots of fried rice.
Boiled rice. Veggies and rice. Buckets of lentils buckets of rain roaring down the roof. Mold.
Creeping across the kitchen wall. All. Mold and white hands through the aldor guitar. And the slush. Of red roads.
Breaking hearts and cars. Favoring cabin families trip to strawberry fields for ever.
Way down the wet gully path and gums and river below. An ocean of meese. Hurrying through sleep.
Into heat the lazy days backwards into town. Blowing dirt. Creek diving. Valley into facing visitors again.
And the garden. Somewhere between in the mirror. Of deep green mountains. And the children.
Rabbits rounder saw in bounds of spring. Heat waving into summers and gone. The art of. Just been lucky.
I've just been man. Of just the hour. Nimbin is kiss and smash. Many many pregnant pauses. Death and birth. And birth.
And birth and. Birth and birth. And birth and death and rebirth. And be on and in the whole room. Outpatients.
And healers. The freedom just to be anything or nothing and. Every morning they hose the town clean. Nimbin.
Is that hallucinogenic smell of the forest days. The wild moondance is still cloning in the wood smoke.
And the pub breath. Misting thick. Above the grand piano. Nimbin is what turns. Suburban refugees.
Into saints or scum bags. De facto husband and wife. Rumors of hot showers.
A thousand new plan to treat the us around the garden of rusting rotting. Nin than. Is fat.
And not at the spot of a of breast milk. Curdles the yellow on fresh. Dolled. Chicks. Newman is what's. Past.
The brood. Of astrology is a new name than is initiation ground. All why. It's take what you need. Give what you can.
And god. The selling of nimbin. Natural. If you please we sell it as cheese. As kero bork our dr banana.
A weekend retreat. Will mess our joy fleet with centered oriole or then tunnel. If your condor leni falls.
Will mud brick. Your walls and cloud. Your hopes. With dopes. We saw by the touch. We sell by the smell. By the pinch.
Or pound or pound or need a stand or i will talk you into the garage. But we charge more to come back and be saved.
Rebirth. Why not. Reincarnation. Way of got ten dollars for the book or a thousand. For the lot. Doubt. Your actuality.
We'll change your sexuality. And we'll wrench. A flower. By the hour. Want to be bored by us to be ignored.
Two weeks in the park will turn your day. Into day. A swim of the pole or drown of the pub or a movie.
Down at the record. With dinner for two. Of blacksnake rice do you. And can deliver talk of the sick to me.
You can marry. Some german. And they'll pay you first certain. It's better than life in an iron curtain.
Or you're after some land or just a sheer. We sell by the. Inch. At prices so rare.
We sell it as dresses and printing presses.
And pottery and plates and solar panels and paintings and poets and postcards and performers and punks.
And potted palm mystery and pure. Herbal therapy. Take a drug home for take eat.
Take some children for free or just a small flea. It's all for sale you see. Even me. Plus designer nudists.
Skateboard meditation and alternative the longer i mean we still. Pawpaw at the plumbers. Khandaan. Of the garridge.
And prescriptions. At the drapery. There's a sky channel at the hotel. With helicopter police as well.
We're all getting straight. All we do the food or. And if you want class. Well we're all in the middle.
You may think i'm joking. Well. Must run my idea. The shops to be open. The tour bus. Is here.